je dois avouer que c'était globalement
l'expérience la plus heureuse que j'ai
jamais eue avec un casting au fait que
vous êtes me voir comme ça hein comme
choisir ce qui est évidemment très
flatté je connaissais les a que de vue
j'avais vu dans un film depuis de
christophe honoré
je trouvais qu'elle était déjà qu'elle
était très belle et qu'elle avait
quelque chose de l as quelque chose à
l'image qui est qui est indéniable elle
n'avait jamais joué une fille comme
comme bell mais je le percevait
fortement quand je regardais les films
dans lequel il avait joué je percevais
7,7 par là chez elle et ça a été une
surprise pour personne qu'elle arrive
sur le plateau et que soit belle et non
plus les assez doux dès le premier jour
la première heure il est clair qu'il ya
une rencontre entre les a et le genre du
film de léa et actrice de cinéma
d'auteur en france a toujours rêvé de
faire un film féerique et il sait et la
rencontre s'est produit
quand on utilise vincent cassel ont
signé une espèce de pacte avec un diable
en tout cas un diablotin c'est à dire
que faisait pas c'est pas un personnage
lisse et je crois que c'était très
important que je n'aille pas contre
l'image de vincent je ne surtout pas je
veux dire les gens aiment vincent pour
une bonne raison pour créer un précédent
dangereux dans le racing est un grand
acteur comme nous on est sur un mode je
crois ludique entre nous et on passe pas
50 ans à se parler de ce que tu crois
que je préfère ça comme ça non pas du
tout c'est complètement les acteurs a
même quelque chose auquel je n'avais pas
pensé et qui met brusquement qui me
fascine d'ailleurs c'est lé moment que
tous les cinéastes cherche